tout châtras tu touche-à-tout saint
quentin nous sommes au seuil juifs
athées des chrétiens c'est la réponse
dans saint quentinois à l'emballement
médiatique des dernières semaines autour
de trappes
le rappeur kirtas a tourné un clip ce
week end devant le lycée de la plaine de
neuf établissements où enseigne et
didier lemaire le professeur de
philosophie qui a fait polémique en
dénonçant l'emprise communautaire dans
la ville les gens ne connaissent pas
très plaisant tendent malheureusement
beaucoup de négatif
et là l'idée après après l'appel de
cette dame houria c'était d'aller un peu
plus loin et d'écrire une chanson
entière
le rap que chez ces véhiculer des
messages et j'ai toujours été dans ce
côté là l'espoir l'entr'aide et le vivre
ensemble
si son morceau qu'il a écrit très
rapidement après la polémique qui veut
redorer l'image de trappes curtin n'en
reste pas moins lucide sur la situation
de la colonne on est conscient qu'il ya
certains problèmes mais ces problèmes là
justement il faut je pense essayer de
trouver des solutions sans comment dire
sans forcément taper du doigt à longueur
de journée parce que ça on n'avance pas
le rappeur n'est pas originaire de la
ville mais kirtas n'a pas été choisi au
hasard pour écrire cette chanson c ur ya
une habitante qui l'a sollicité pour
revaloriser l'image de sa commune
yao rire qui m'appelle encore une fois
sa ville est sous le feu des projecteurs
pas pour dire quel était il a toujours
participé aux événements de la commune
donc pour moi c'était c'était une
évidence j'adore ces écritures il a il a
des mots plutôt assez simple et puis en
même temps les le message qu'il véhicule
auprès des jeunes me correspond
parfaitement
donc bien sûr c'est un peu comme une
évidence pour moi le clip de kurt a
ainsi que la chanson sortiront mercredi
24 février sur sa chaîne youtube un
morceau qu'il espère voir partager le
plus possible
c'est la culture la mixité tous unis
pour trouver des solutions
on rigole bien nos blagues de jamel ne
souvient thomas rssi grandement nous
booste et comme l'a dit le grand abd al
malik en acquitte ont fait plus de vécu
forêt qui pousse